yeah yeah sit yeah let's start with this
I fully fully 100 thousand percent with
no hedge do not believe that you can
teach entrepreneurship right so that's
awkward you know uh you know what I mean
what I mean by that is that you know
it's crazy for me that that word is now
considered like cool and good like when
I was your age twenty years ago
entrepreneur meant that you were a
[ __ ] loser that was figuring it out
right so watching watching what's
happening to the world right now where
this has become a hot topic is
interesting to me and like I'm super
pumped that people now value that in a
different way than they did the way I
mean I grew up a DNF student right and
and the reason I grew up a DNF student
was I was unable to sit in a room like
this and listen to whoever was sitting
up here
because all I wanted to do was sell [ __ ]
right and so that's all I've ever known
I've had no other gear somewhere around
fourth grade when I got an F on a
science test I literally like that day
was like yeah that makes sense to me
because I don't give a [ __ ] about Saturn
right like like like I don't that's not
who I am and so I think I think if there
was anything I could do if there was
anything I could do that would be
awesome for you guys to make the most
money I could make I would create a test
or or a drug that allowed people to
become self-aware I think the number one
thing that I could tell you because I'm
desperate to bring value since I'm here
is I think everybody lies to themselves
and I think all of you want certain
things to be happening with you you want
yourself to be something and I think
what you need to do more of and if I can
give you clearly I'm coming out the gate
with my best piece of advice I really do
think uh you know you have to audit who
you actually are I think that America as
a society has done a really good job in
selling us how to fix the things that we
naturally aren't and there's a lot of
money being made on us forming into
something we can't be and I either
through massive ego and bravado complete
ignorant I don't know what it was early
on in my life maybe this the outrageous
level of self-esteem that my mom
instilled in me I was able to quickly
very very early on and let me take it
back because a lot of you don't know I
was born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union and so I came here when I was
three and we were super poor you know I
lived in a studio apartment I know what
it tastes like to walk five miles to
Kmart buy toilet paper come home and
then sit there for an hour and split the
toilet paper to get efficiency that's a
huge advantage for me right like the
fact that I've been working 19 hours a
day every day for the last 20 years is
easy for me it's the only gear I knew
right I was poor I sucked [ __ ] at school
it was the only gear I had right so like
I said here with enormous disrespect and
with enormous assumptions around all of
you that you're just too soft to beat me
right that I think that you've had it
better and that that alone doesn't allow
you to beat me and that's how I think of
entrepreneurship in a very rugged very
raw much dirtier way I've been investing
for about seven years the first three
things I invested in in 2007 after I
built my wine business and I realized
this internet thing was going to be big
right was was Facebook Twitter and
Tumblr right and then I've collectively
gotten stupider since that moment mainly
because I didn't think of myself as an
investor when I invested in those
companies I just thought that EV
Williams sucks
and David Carper really [ __ ] smart
and we're gonna win right and so like
when I think about uber like Travis is
one of my best best buddies like now he
has a lot of press and I'm sure a lot of
you know who he is that just makes a lot
of sense because all the negative press
he gets makes sense because he's a
fighter but he was the only CEO of that
company because ubers had a fight City
Hall for the last four years it's hard
to fight the Mafia that owns the taxi
service in Vegas that takes like I can't
do that like I'm too not confrontational
right so I think that the number one
thing that you can do the the you know
I'm desperately competi
and want to be the person that brings
the most value to you out of all these
talks like I secretly sit here and say
oh they're going to get all these people
that they've heard of but I'm gonna be
the one that tells them something that
actually [ __ ] matters and that one
thing is you need to bet on your
strengths and don't give a [ __ ] about
what you suck at you're gonna way too
many people this room are gonna spend
the next 30 40 years of their lives
trying to check the boxes other things
that they're not as good at and that
you're going to waste a fuckload of time
and lose I highly recommend auditing
yourself or if you have no [ __ ]
empathy or EQ or self-awareness then
find somebody in your family or
friendship that does and let them tell
you who you are and once you believe
that either for yourself or someone else
told you go directly all chips all into
that because that is the only possible
way in my opinion watching from the
outside that is limited phrase that is a
very highly likely way of over-indexing
because the truth is if you want to be
an anomaly you've got to act like one
you know like and so that's it that's
what I got so thanks for having me I
think that um I think that uh I think
that it's been really interesting for me
for the last three years to watch so
tech when I was investing in it for me
and when I was growing my business in
the 90s and then when I really got into
it you know four or five six seven you
know people were in it because they were
really good at it or in it or really
passionate right now everybody thinks
that if you're 22 and you have an idea
you're entitled to a startup right and
so the thing that's been really
fascinating for me to watch the
dichotomy of structure and understanding
how to play the game versus
entrepreneurship so for example again
being a dick about it I know I'm sitting
in a room full of number twos threes and
fours right there's so many people in
this room that are like going to be dot
like could be dominant number two threes
and fours and I'm pissed that the
narrative now is that you need to be a
number one and have your company because
a lot of people going to lose or leave
money on the table because that's just
the narrative right and so the
difference for me between a two three
and four and a one is having a stomach
and so one of the things that we've seen
a lot of because succs went to Harvard
and like
really being East Coast bound like
watching all these kids that are going
to Ivy League schools including Stanford
so mixing the whole egg mix there's like
actually everybody's a better student I
was so I'll just call it everybody but
watching the elite top 3% so many of
those players guys and gals have come
into the game in the last 24 36 months
and have lived a narrative where things
have been good right like like you know
again I'm using a lot of prejudice I
default into thinking that like you guys
were way more capable than me then
figuring out how to map yourselves to go
through the school system like you
understood that game like very honestly
like it's cool to be like oh [ __ ] school
and I sucked and then I was a great
entrepreneur but like it would have been
cool to have figured it out like I would
have been fine getting season B's right
like that would've been interesting then
you know that like then I would have had
a better life like it like college
would've been more fun and one wouldn't
have went to Mount Ida College where
seven of my eight core friends [ __ ]
went to jail right so you know I want to
keep it real
so you know so but I just couldn't and I
think that that's what I'm seeing the
reverse of right now which is on the
flip side being an entrepreneur and
really running a successful company
here's the problem there isn't just like
one teacher who [ __ ] decides and you
figured out how to map him or to
syllabus or whatever the [ __ ] you guys
do to figure out what you needed the
problem is when you have a start-up or a
business you're playing to the market
and the market doesn't give a [ __ ] who
your parents were or how you rolled or
what happened before the market just
cares about the market and so I think
that what's been really interesting for
me to observe and and I would say is
something for you guys to think about is
again you're going to want to think in a
certain way versus what may be the
reality or you might underestimate
yourself it just depends on your DNA but
the ability to adjust is the entire game
like I'm so proud that I changed my mind
every day my dad used to get so pissed
when I was building wine library he
would always be like [ __ ] he's like he
would say like three months ago you said
Ricky was going to be the best employee
and like I changed my mind he [ __ ] fire
him or or he's like you said sparkling
wine was important now you just
eliminated it from the key spot I'm like
I
changed my mind like my ability to only
be comfortable in massive chaos has been
my biggest asset as an entrepreneur like
I would never take a [ __ ] note like
that scares the piss out of me what
these three people are doing right now
right and so now yeah now that may work
for them and I'm not like back to the
opening statement like you need to do
you like some plenty of people that make
a fuckload more money than me and one
bigger take [ __ ] notes the key the
key though the key is way too many
people are doing like here's a good one
you know what really pissed me the [ __ ]
off
I'm completely driven by like happiness
and like I'm crippled by like chaos like
you know vaynermedia which is not 500
people update your [ __ ] vaynermedia is
like completely dictated but like I'm a
dictator of HR like all I care about is
the atmosphere all I care about is how
people intern all I care about is like
how people roll like I think I've fired
four most talented smartest people that
have worked for me because if you don't
know how to play with the other boys and
girls you're out because I suffocate
under you know conflict and negativity
and like nobody's better than me so you
got to go so what really pissed me off
in tech world was when Steve Jobs his
book came out when he was dying when it
was all about Steve three or four years
ago I literally watched a lot of my tech
startup friends start being like a dick
to their staff because Jobs was tough
everybody fell into the romance of like
I have this big vision and I'm gonna be
a dick like Steve right and I thought
that was really interesting for me to
watch that half decade of like literally
watching people I know and then watching
them act differently because the status
or the icon of the moment and you see a
lot of that and so like that is probably
the energy I'm trying to bring to this
class today which is you can look at
like how people roll and like it's great
to admire and things of that nature but
it's so damn important to stick to like
your DNA right and like what you're good
at and to recognize that you need to
surround yourself whether it's your
co-founder or whether it's the people
that work for you like all I do is
I earn the people that are the opposite
of me that bring the other value that
bring me the ability to remember what
the [ __ ] that meeting was about and go
make sure it happens you know like
whatever it may be right and so I think
that's another thing that I would highly
recognize I think the other thing you
guys should recognize is how
ridiculously lucky you are
but how interesting the supply and
demand of your luck is changing meaning
it's never been better to be an
entrepreneur like right now right this
second is the greatest there's massive
disruption I promise you because I spend
a fuckload of time with everybody in
corporate America the big companies are
so [ __ ] slow and stupid it's almost
unbearable right so that's great for us
if we don't have money and we've got
time right and so that's great and and
the cost of entry is easy there's so
many people that are envious of the
lucky things that happen to me investing
in like uber and Birchbox and Twitter
and all those things that now everybody
in their 30s to 60s that has any level
of money is chasing any kid in a hoodie
with an idea and giving them money to
invest in their startup because
everybody's looking for their exit right
so on top of the fact that the internet
is hitting maturity and every users on a
smartphone in blah blah blah and we're
at scale on top of that in parallel
there's a fuckload of dumb money chasing
it and looking it to give it to anybody
they can which is your opportunity so we
need to take advantage of that horseshit
and actually if you think you're ready
you should literally start your company
right now because I'm sure it's
important to finish this class and
whatever but tomorrow the market can
collapse and you'll miss this
opportunity literally right now on a
[ __ ] half-ass idea right with like
two or three connections from like your
parents or professors or emailing me and
I interview somebody you can literally
raise a million dollars on your
horseshit idea but we need to like want
like I want everybody understand that
all it takes is something crazy like a
terrorist attack or some [ __ ] Bank
full of [ __ ] breaking or all in like
tomorrow that can go away and so like I
think it's super important for everybody
understand that if you're itching I
think you should start tomorrow because
the money's there and you're going to
need the money because this happens all
the time like everybody that looked like
you in 2008-9 they went and got
everybody looked like you in 2002 and
three after the first bubble they went
and got jobs so if you're true
entrepreneur if you're sitting here like
no I'm entrepreneur I'm not just in the
class you need to seriously concentrate
on where we are at this exact moment in
the market and recognize how fruitful it
is for you how much of an advantage you
have you may want to seriously consider
and take advantage of it because I could
really go away in a second and then
you've got a way to like if it collapses
tomorrow if there's a bubble burst
you're gonna have to wait three to five
years to get your shot when bubbles
bursts no [ __ ] kid with an idea gets
dick got it that's a good one um I like
that one but that's what happens so so I
think that's important
timing is massively important and so
that's why I'm pushing that agenda bless
you I think the other thing to think the
other thing to think about is uh I think
that here's just some random [ __ ] and
then maybe we can go into Q&A I think
that uber Airbnb and instacart are not
anomalies the way a lot of people in my
world think I think they're just a
preview I think if everybody here
understands that the number one asset to
everybody in the world is time and if
you can figure out how to buy and sell
it back that's a big coup so I think the
biggest reason I got excited about her
years ago was I realized holy [ __ ]
this isn't about transportation this is
about a company that sells me back time
as a matter of fact I actually boycotted
LA for four years I actually didn't come
to LA for four years because I hated
[ __ ] coming here so much because I
didn't want to rent a car and the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] hated this place
literally I started now I'm back all the
time because Buber because I can get
around right like I can actually move
and so that was good um but back to the
main point it's stunning for me to watch
people's behavior literally
fundamentally we care about the health
of our loved ones money and then time
and I think if you really look at what
uber is doing its selling back time and
I think if you're thinking in start-up
mode if you're looking for an
inspirational seed as a starting point I
highly recommend thinking about time
people massively overpay for you love
time so much in realize that think about
the last
your phone or your computer was a
hundredth of a second slower than what
you're used to on Wi-Fi how [ __ ]
pissed you are like that's how much we
like time and so that is a big theme
that I think is going to play out
and so again recognizing some not
everybody here has their full idea or
everything you know figured out I think
that's an important place to play I
think the other thing that's really
important is I think I play the game a
little bit backwards so I publicly give
away all my best ideas all of them I
recognize as an individual I'm not going
to be able to go and execute every great
idea every great thought I have and so
I've lived the light for the last seven
years where I put out all my content at
scale whether through blog I'm writing a
lot of medium right now if you don't
know that as you check it out it's
really rad you know stuff like that and
so I think early on in one's career and
definitely I watch a lot of people that
don't understand what's happening now is
the value of your thoughts can be
extreme so I highly recommend thinking
about putting your thoughts out to the
world in whatever way you communicate
whether through audio podcast or written
form for medium or video blog if you're
thinking about entrepreneurship if
you're thinking about trends if you're
thinking about business you're literally
just one three-minute read on a medium
away from creating a huge gateway drug
to a lot of opportunity if your thought
is deemed as smart or forward-thinking
or different by another thought later or
somebody's got an opportunity and I'm
surprised I think this is very residual
from the way it used to be in the world
of patents and ideas I love when my my
assistants got a great thing now in this
once in every four months somebody sends
an email saying I've got a huge startup
that I want you to invest in but you've
got to sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says [ __ ] you right and and the
reason is I'm a humongous believer that
ideas are [ __ ] and that executions the
game right we've all got ideas
everybody's got ideas do any [ __ ]
ideas we all have here we can probably
sit here for the next two hours draw
them all out record them and predict the
next 78 great startups over the next
nine years and so I think the thing that
is another theme in entrepreneurship is
there is way too much fodder brought to
the idea Hoover was magic cab three
years earlier
uber is not an idea uber existed it's
called magic cab but the guys that
execute it sucked so they lost so I
think you know if there's any level of
romance left in this room about your
idea I'd like to suffocate it because I
think the actual situation is what you
actually do with it and so that leads me
to the last point I'm you know maybe
it's because I was born in a communist
country maybe it's because I came from
zero but I really think that people who
think that are entrepreneurs that don't
work 15 to 17 hours a day aren't I
really believe that I
I'm sure that's short-sighted and
one-dimensional but I just believe it
without my entire soul like it blows me
away of watching the startups I'm
investing in where they're like leaving
half-day Friday during the summer to go
to the Hamptons to like hook up like you
know cool I get it and it's wish I could
do it but I think that uh I think that
there's a I think there's a pretty
substantial soft mentality in the game
right now and what's deemed as hard work
is uh is probably not going to be deemed
as hard work by your grandparents or
great-grandparents and definitely the
opportunity at hand when you're taking
people's money I mean look I I think one
thing that should be talked about as
well as I would say 80% of the kids that
I'm giving money to between 22 and 25 as
you can tell I'm not traditional and so
we get nice relationships I would say
80% of them tell me right to my face
there's that they actually have no worry
whatsoever to lose my money that it's
awesome right like I'm sure you're
thinking it too like cool I'll raise a
million bucks I'll learn a fuckload if I
lose I'm still just 26 I got plenty of
time I'll take all that experience and
I'll go apply it let me tell you one
thing about that experience and applying
it one of the things that's very
dangerous if you think you're going to
be great I highly recommend that you be
very smart about how you go about this
because the thing that most people don't
talk about is the fact that that
checkbox in the lost column eliminates
you from a lot of opportunity the next
go
around and so a lot of people right now
they're taking money and just starting
[ __ ] because it's easy and and who knows
and it's like [ __ ] roll it right what
what's happening is when you lose all
the people that are you're going to look
for might bless you all the people you
look for money in the future and the
market and your [ __ ] Wikipedia that
say you [ __ ] lost and all that [ __ ]
it's all there and so I think there's a
lack of thinking about legacy and
long-term marathon thinking right now in
a sprinters mentality where there is a
lot of access to capital and everything
feels shiny so I'd like to instill some
level of giving a [ __ ] about 10 or 14 or
19 years out to I'd like to do some Q&A
if that's cool yeah man what's your name
che che Shane
I like che better that's a great
question so I think you can start so
perfect thanks I am a contradiction so
[ __ ] you Shane I think I think you do
both and this is what I mean right like
there's a big difference between going
to like 15 tech conferences using all
your leverage getting to everybody
that's at up here saying you've got it
getting those checks versus you know
barring like 30 grand from a fret for
its friend or your parents or you know
there's a way to could do both right and
so I would do both I mean if you look
whoo let's play this game and don't
[ __ ] me
because I might call on you and then
expose you how many people here really
really think they've got their idea and
they're ready to go I really think you
should leave with all my [ __ ] heart
like leave right the [ __ ] like walk out
of this room and go do it right so
because I really believe that like
tomorrow something bad can happen and
it's really good for you guys right now
like you could really get 200,000 like
you know this right like like it's like
it's crazy the default that we think of
how easy it is to get money you know
hard it was to get money in 1998 when I
came out of the game like you couldn't
get 50 bucks from somebody right like
like it's so [ __ ] bonkers because
Hollywood dictates thinking guys sucks
is [ __ ] movie [ __ ] with people's
heads and you're taking advantage of
that so I think that
what happens is and listen this is me
being a story in' i wasn't in the game
for web 1.0 bubble i was in new jersey
building a wine store during web 1.0
bubble so i wasn't in those little cosmo
calm pet calm game i was being practical
with my $15,000 a year in marketing and
building my business I mean all those
guys and gals did the same thing they
[ __ ] went out they have the moment
that you have right now they [ __ ]
were worth of drilling in on paper
because everything when I peel back then
right and then like April happened and
everybody lost everything and they were
all working for like Fox and like
[ __ ] the New York Times and like
Conde Nest the next [ __ ] day and so
you know ah you know one more time Kluth
who's got it
who's got it right now you need to
really really debate it and like the
only dynamic that I would even accept is
like you love your parents so much and
they're still so [ __ ] old school that
it would hurt their feelings but other
than that there's literally no other
excuse questions yes well the things
with with tumblr Twitter and Facebook
they had already won like I love when
people like he was such a forward
thinker I'm like I'll take it but [ __ ]
though we're already were winning right
like it was 2007 like Facebook was
[ __ ] huge right like Twitter I felt
like I just felt intuitive about Twitter
right like I just coming from email
marketing and like being a marketer and
a Salesman I understood how building an
audience and in that audience like email
marketing was like you blasted people
and they did [ __ ] but like forwarding
emails to your entire dress book that
died by like 99 right and so and so when
Twitter came thinking like I was going
to push something out and then people
like I'll pass that on I was like [ __ ]
word-of-mouth right and like so Twitter
is a product spoke to me it's why I've
over indexed on it's been my foundation
that was a little bit different than EV
you know who's who I bet on more than
jack it was more EV and my whole theory
on that was well he built bloggers and
sold it to Google like he's already won
once
right and that was kind of a nice thing
it's fun to bet on somebody who's been
able to see it through
tumblr was interesting tumblr so I'm a
straight creeper right like so on the
way here today at JFK I literally like
got to my gate looked around found like
four 13 year old girls literally sat
behind them and watched everything they
did right so by the way real quick if
you ever hear that I go to jail just
knows market research and I did that
today and what did I watch I watched I
watched them spend 99% of their time on
Instagram
Yik yak and snapchat right and so that's
what happened with me and tumblr in 2007
like it was a little different than it
was laptops phones are better you look
less creepy I just started getting a
sense that junior high kids were on
tumblr way more than anybody was talking
about it that was a good one for me
because I'm new york-based karpas in New
York Karp is super artist I'm super
businessman so there was a nice yin and
yang I knew how to renew her to respect
that [ __ ] nerd [ __ ] and not scare
them and so yeah it just worked out
right like it I mean this is how insane
2009 was I joined tumblr and tumblr on
the dashboard put garyvee joins tumblr
on everybody's dashboard for a week it
was just a different world I got an
inner series B at 14 million they had
users now like somebody farts an idea
and gets 14 million pre-product
so it was a different market Birchbox is
probably the best one Birchbox had 60
knows we wrote the first check how many
people are familiar with Birchbox cool
so Birchbox if you don't know you should
check it out to Harvard HBS girls they
got like 60 knows I remember sitting in
that meeting and investing on the spot
and they were super pumped and they then
they told me they got sixty knows which
was probably a smart strategic move and
I remember just leaving that meeting
thinking like that was just straight
sexism right like that was the only
thing I could wrap my head around like
that people just didn't want to invest
in the girls just like I couldn't
understand because the model was
phenomenal it's like hey here's our
business model we're gonna sell people
make up samples that we get for free
right like and so back to the back to my
first business of ripping people's
flowers ringing their doorbell and
selling it felt like
I'm like this is a good model no
overhead and then I remember telling
them I'm like look if we can do customer
acquisition at scale and get enough
leverage eventually makeup brands are
gonna pay you to be in there and that's
what's happened with that company so
that one was more them they were so
sharp I have never liked you know I'm
acutely aware of like racism like I got
out of Russia by being Jewish right like
my parents were super persecuted in the
Soviet Union and so I've always been
hypersensitive to it but that one was
the most extreme case because they
crushed and knew what they were doing
and it's great to watch that go out and
actually become such a big company but
simple things like Yik yak right I
[ __ ] up and didn't see it through but
which I'm pissed about but the only
reason I even reached out to them just
to give you an example like messing up
nine or ten months ago I could have
gotten in a four million dollar
valuation they just raised at a 350
million dollar valuation and the only
reason I got to that gateway is that
every morning when I wake up and go take
a crap the first thing I do on my phone
is look at the iTunes top 150 free apps
and Yik yak just started showing up 150
137 123 123 look the [ __ ] is this right
and secret and whisper we're getting all
the Silicon Valley attention yet they
weren't even showing up on that and just
new normal kids were doing it so same
thing happens nap chatted remember
creeping on 13 year old girls for a
couple months and being like the [ __ ] is
that yellow thing on their on their
phone like it's always showing up that
was good because it was yellow was easy
like see fast and not get like beat up
by their dad and so and so I I spend all
of my time looking at behavior like at
the end of the day all I do is reverse
engineer behavior and that's what and
that's what I figured out I was good at
right like I was good at because I was
such a great salesman I was able to
reverse engineer as I got more mature
and older I'm like ah I'm a great
salesman because I actually am really
paying attention to what you're doing
like when I took over my dad's liquor
store buy I made a lot of money as a
teenager selling baseball cards all I
used to do is stand behind a baseball
card table and just people in malls
would walk by and look at your case and
I would just literally watch their eyes
and be like what are they responding to
so like ui/ux like my designer friends
are always freaked out of how good I am
it because they think I'm a business guy
shouldn't be good at that but that's all
I've ever done my whole life at scale I
feel like I'm doing it right now I'm
like watching what's happening here and
so I use my EQ to like do my thing but
and and that's why I'm such a big fan of
betting on strengths I think that's the
unknown thing about sucks
I mean sucks gets portrayed definitely
in the movie and just in general like
he's got crazy EQ he like really
understands people like I think he's a
really smart entrepreneur yes what's
your name how are you good yeah yeah you
know regrets are interesting for me like
I'm sure look I have a ton of them right
I pack if you go if you go look at my
first book it's called crush it in there
I thank my entire family and one random
human being Travis Cal Connect CEO and
co-founder of uber and I passed on the
angel round of uber I literally left
seven hundred million dollars on the
table by not investing in my buddy after
I just told you you bet on people and
this and that it happens right so I have
plenty of things to regret right I
regret the fact that I that I and look
don't cry for me I'm going to make two
hundred million dollars because we got
again the next round but but but I
regret that when I was doing opencart
optimization on winelibrary.com in 1997
that I wasn't smart enough to realize
that if I turned that into a product and
sold it to Amazon for five hundred
million dollars I would have made a
fuckload more money than selling
eighteen more bottles of Pinot Noir
right so I but very honestly you've got
me pegged I'm basically not capable of
really regretting it I'm trying to
answer your question and not be a
douchebag about it but regretting feels
to me like the opposite of
entrepreneurship right like I just think
it means looking back and I think speed
is the number one variable that most
people in this room will struggle with
that is the variable difference that I
that's what Travis and sucks sucks moved
fatso
when Mark bought Instagram for a billion
dollars a couple months earlier I did
some Fox program and I said that I was
like it was December they're like hey
make some predictions for 23
13 I was like Facebook's going to buy
Instagram right cool
whatever four months later it happens
and CNN asks me to come on because the
video went a little viral in the tech
community so I was on Piers Morgan and
on Piers Morgan's show he his opening
line is this company's five hundred
fifty days old how the hell is it worth
a billion dollars
and my opening line is they stole it I
get out of the studio I'm hardcore
Twitter so I go on it and literally
there are thousands of tweets of people
calling me a [ __ ] idiot so literally
that night from like 10 o'clock at night
to 4 in the morning i favorited every
single one of those tweets by hand all
of them yeah I think it's a good story
because this is what an entrepreneur I
think does I favor to them all and then
I guess last year this time right
Facebook bought whatsapp for 18 billion
and every article like the next day
after the news came out is like oh wait
a minute they [ __ ] stole Instagram
and no joke for a week my wife and I
went to Turks and Caicos for a weekend
right luckily she just likes to read and
I can't bother her and I laid on a beach
for 19 hours a day two days in a row and
replied to every single person that
called me an idiot and said what now
[ __ ] I really think I just wanted to
get that in and humble brag but I don't
remember why I said that
oh why I said it sup so zux offered
three billion for snapchat and a lot of
people didn't like like that seemed
insane but like I don't think anybody
thinks that's insane anymore right and
so what he's really smart is he
understands the gateway drug is
important to him because the
fifteen-year-old girl right now in
America is not going to be a facebook
user and so he needs to keep having the
next one right luckily he's got the
right one right now with Instagram but
every day that snapchat becomes the next
one he needs to figure that out but I
think he sees it and so like it takes
that vision Travis knew that he had to
move to every market faster than lyft
right and so he just kept raising money
if he could and that was the right
execution so I think speed is something
that people really need to wrap their
head
yeah man Alex what's up man I think
every platform is gonna be a media
company and so I think it makes a ton of
sense I think everybody in this room is
gonna watch like a feature film that's
gonna be Facebook only I think they'll
be a number-one hit sitcom on snapchat
only there's a all that matters is the
attention graph right where the [ __ ] are
our eyes and ears where are they right
and I can tell you right now if I want
to sell to a 16 year old girl in America
I want to be in snapchat right so I
thought it was a huge coup for the media
companies that were launch partners
because some of them I think we'd all
agree are like stodgy and not great and
like and for them this was a little bit
of good value I think it was a really
smart move by snapchat because I really
live in this world a lot of the big
advertisers look at them as too young
you only have 13 year olds so this kind
of like grew them up I think Emily white
is a really interesting executive for a
lot of people in this room I think she's
super asked inspirational boys and girls
in this room like Emily white if you
don't know her Google Facebook Instagram
and now the CEO of snapchat I think
she's a beast and I think it was a
really smart play because it instantly
made them more mature right like I've
been [ __ ] yelling about snapchat for
like two years finally when that
happened I got like 9 thousand emails
from like old [ __ ] white dudes saying
oh I was like a dick you know like like
oh you know like like hundreds of
millions of people's attention [ __ ]
matters like do I have to run what
pisses me off where you're seeing I'm
getting a little pissed this Facebook
just went through this it's not like
we're going like the first time makes
sense right like it never happened
before but like Facebook was only
college kids now it's your [ __ ]
grandmother like that's what happens and
so like that will kick the fastest
growth on Instagram right now is 40 to
50 year old women the fastest growing
sector of people taking selfies fastest
growing so it's a smaller base but it's
still volume fastest growth of selfies
taken on Instagram are 40 to 45 year old
women like straight up [ __ ] cougar
selfies
right like and like watch and again back
to like watching I'm watching people
like have conversations real quick off
that reaction and people again my
[ __ ] lot like like people know you
know like people know what's going on
right like your mom's on Instagram now
24 months ago she didn't know what it
was not just what it is that's just
what's always going to happen because
what's happening is we're living through
the age of vacation like the downward
age of vacation of society the number
one thing I love right now is that the
average forty to forty two-year-old
American woman in her behavior the
clothes she buys what she does how she
hangs out with her friends is acting
like the average twenty nine-year-old
woman only ten years ago like nobody
wants to be old I'm 39 like I shouldn't
be like dressed like you know with a 39
year old version of me look like 15
years ago like nobody wants like nobody
wants get old like it's like it sucks
and there's a flip side to it whereas
only ten years ago a fifteen-year-old
would look up to their 18 year old
sibling and listen to the same music and
all that that's why you're seeing
snapchat and Yik yak and other things
there's a fragmentation even within
generations like they want their own
[ __ ] thing and in a much shorter
period of time like used to be more like
seven to ten years now you're like
seeing three years is okay but like
after that like there's a lot of people
in here that like their high school
siblings that are younger than them
don't want to [ __ ] with the things that
they [ __ ] with and so it's it's
interesting what's going on with the
psychology of generations and people the
youth of vacation of our society thanks
brother
yeah only failing back then I was a
great question
oh I want to make sure like I don't want
to stop anybody because they don't want
to fail I just want I just wanted to say
this there's a shitload of audacity in
the market right now like who gives a
[ __ ] I'm gonna lose this money over the
next three years but it's gonna be good
for me because I'm gonna have experience
not gonna work a dick job I'm gonna do
what I want and and then I'll figure it
out after the fact I think it's I think
failings fine look I have a couple
people that have failed and I'm gonna
reinvest in their next idea I just want
to make sure that you're you think
you're ready and you're not just doing
it because it's easy money right now so
if you think you're good like I have a
huge fail right now that I can't I'm
gonna invest in this kid the whole way
because I've watched him fail but I've
seen all the great things he did the
market and his idea were off a little
bit but he's a [ __ ] assassin so I
just want him that's what I wanted to
clarify and I'm glad you did that
because I think he made it better better
Shan Shan sorry but waited way to have
his back [ __ ] United class yeah I
would do what I did which was like not
give a [ __ ] about school and start
prepping for my life that but that's
what I did right it's not like I'm not
telling you like what is cool to say in
a room of kids I'm telling you what the
[ __ ] I did like go Google Mount Ida
College like like like I did you do that
okay I thought you did it yeah so like
you know like I I had no other gear
right so but I truly feel I was 100%
purebred entrepreneur I truly believe
that and I truly believe that it's
probably a high significant chance that
nobody in this class is and that's not
bad I promise you 90% and 85% and 80%
can be dramatically more successful than
me I probably could have used a little
10 or 20% of other stuff that would have
leveled me out I was just [ __ ] off
the chart yeah man
yep there ever a point where you felt
like you had to leverage my dad had a
liquor store right and so that made it a
little bit different so I think you know
I came from zero early on but by the
time my dad lived the American dream so
it'd be a false to see that I did all by
myself there was a super small business
it was a three million dollar revenue
business with ten percent gross margin
we made three hundred thousand before
expenses that wasn't a big business but
I knew at fourteen that I could be that
I was way better than my dad right and I
was pumped because I was so thankful for
what my dad did because like we came
here and had nothing and then we had
something right so I had this incredible
family pride to come in and pay him back
right and walk into a family business
that's doing 3 million and in 24 months
be doing 12 million and like like I had
to buy my own car like at a garage sale
by the way and then my brother who's 11
years younger me got a Lexus like I'm a
little bitter but like I'm super proud
of that part so I'm not sure like I have
a little bit of a different like
everybody we all have our different net
look look I used to be super
disrespectful to rich kids but now that
they're all my friends
I now realize like [ __ ] they got a
shitty - right like I have a bunch of
friends who are like [ __ ] really
struggling to try to navigate like that
they weren't that they didn't start on a
third and a half base and they're trying
to do it their way and so look
everybody's got their [ __ ] right but
what I can tell you what when I think
about entrepreneurship I couldn't
breathe like I couldn't breathe all I
could ever do was think about what I was
going to sell and what I was like there
was no I mean like I struggled to even
give a [ __ ] about girls like in my late
teenage years and in her early 20s and
like that's just natural to like give a
[ __ ] right and I struggle till I get
there because like I actually did better
with girls than I deserve to because I
literally reverse engineered them
because if they would they would realize
like they would realize that I literally
rather go to the mall and go to the
dollar store and buy something for a
dollar and go to a flea market on
Saturday and sell it for three then like
hang out with them so they like me
because they were like what the [ __ ]
right like it became if it actually gave
me a good preview to a solid thesis
later on but it it was like that's how
raw it was and so that's what I look for
a lot of the people that I'm excited
about them there's a start-up that I'm
investigating called launch starter it's
literally a SAS play for [ __ ]
landscapers right but like I invested in
a second because I'm like oh this
[ __ ] like me right like there was
just nothing else it was all blow pops
in junior high it was all like [ __ ]
whatever right like whatever
yeah man seriously [ __ ] okay I'll come
back what's your name man
Johnny yeah I probably I probably invest
eighty percent eighty percent time if
I'm investing I fully embody into the
jockey and I believe enough in their
horse right like you can show me a
hustler that like me and he's like I'm
gonna [ __ ] sell pillows that [ __ ]
going like I'm gonna [ __ ] you right like
no matter how much I love you right
uh but I'm oftentimes very romance by
the idea but don't believe the kids can
execute it and so it's a mix but I
probably I will here so here's my
strategy if I think you've got the chops
I may still write a small check just to
get into your ecosystem double check you
and try to make sure I get on the second
third and fourth once you mature out and
maybe actually have a good idea so a lot
of times so that's why I'm going that's
why I bet on jockeys because I want to
catch them on the next thing on the next
thing on the next thing and you know
when somebody writes you that first
check you know look some people are
gonna stay loyal something could happen
but like I win that game I get I have
good stickiness by like being a good
dude and by like betting on someone and
so that's a little bit of my strategy
for me cool guys thanks so much for
having me oh well I'm leaving yeah I
know you gotta rest of the class oh this
is I mean
have we ever squeezed 45w be used to the
rest of your life this is remarkable
really right now this this guy talks a
lot of places you've seen him online
seen this what are you talking about
none these [ __ ] even know who I was
they got to read your email Wow wanted
to get him here for a couple years and
one of our common friends made the
connection that happen so we don't know
when he's gonna come back but I saw
everyone right I know what you picked up
so let's give him a little bit something
to think about five years from now and
maybe five minutes from now what are you
not going to forget about this talk Nick
Geary can take with him good ready oh
this is cool I like that are your
strengths and forget about what you suck
at go on on your strengths don't give a
[ __ ] about your weaknesses oh my god
understand the gateway drug hmm time
execution and behavior ideas are [ __ ]
execution is the game ability to adjust
time speak up if you want to be an
anomaly you have to act like value of
thoughts are extreme speed is key you
need to be you if you're aging start
tomorrow you got to be hungry audit
yourself you go I like that Johnny Damon
type character in a rough corner who's
over on the other side go last one right
there one more anyone else here you go
bet on your strengths don't give a [ __ ]
about your weaknesses nice guys get dick
grow I when you take things out of
context it's like
thanks guys
sit